I think I know why is as good as you he
is you 25 years ago they made you from
me they chose me because there's never
been anybody like me we have to end this
right now
what do you tap into when you got to
play a 23 year old yeah it's really you
know what what was great as I had so
much filmography so Angwin and grabs six
degrees of separation you grab bad boys
and Independence Day so the the the team
at Wetty was working off of the
essentially the look of the bad boys and
six degrees of separation a drink so
they were creating around those images
but you can't you can't fake innocence
that was the thing that was really hard
it's a whole lot easier to play older
than it is to play younger it's like
there's certain things once you know
them it's hard to get them get them out
of there at night you know there's
certain knowledge that just takes root
in your cells you know that it's hard to
it's hard to get out of there but it was
it was you know fun to watch all of my
old stuff it was a little bit a little
bit of that and also to see just the the
quality of insanity I was living in in
in that age like like not knowing is
actually a superpower if it doesn't kill
you like you'd like not knowing what you
can do and you didn't know anything it's
that naivete is such a power because
you'll try anything there's a line in
the film where you were younger will
says I am the best and older wills like
you're obviously obviously not the best
so what would you tell younger will that
will and his 20s right now to kind of
prepare him for where you are today well
first of all will in his twenties wasn't
listening to nothing and nobody has his
there so that's that s person were first
of course I wouldn't tell his dumb ass
nothing but there were there were
certain qualities that
I had in my twenties that I've been
trying to recover in the last couple of
years yeah so you know my birthday last
year I went a did bungy jumping out of a
helicopter over the Grand Canyon and
even a part of that foolishness was
trying to get rid of the the fear that I
had taken on as I became more successful
I didn't I didn't become more brave like
I became more fearful as I got older
right so young will was wildly
courageous like he would go to the
courageous courageous to the level of
foolishness but I would want to ask my
younger self about the source of that
courage because I've actually lost touch
with that with that source I have to
manipulate it a little more now than I
used to
[Music]